thank you
well hey you guys what's going on it's
kind of dark in here yes because we
didn't turn the lights off Oh I thought
that one was on but I guess I forgot to
turn that one on I turned that one on
but now it's like way too bright
yeah you might it should be enough right
there you might want to tone that down
you think
yeah turn it down yeah
that seems better but you come in here
and see how it looks yeah see that's
that looks better actually this one
should come on too and damn are you sure
I don't think we usually put that one on
I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do well I
know
all right
that should be good hey everybody what's
going on hey Tammy hey murder Hornet hey
Sebastian
uh murder Hornet says never buy habanero
flavored tabasco hot as [__] while I
wasn't planning on it that sounds like
more like something Tom would like I'd
love that yeah yeah like I said he's
drinking he's drinking the ghost the
ghost pepper yeah go tequila
my brother gave me
Mandy says I love the hair yeah thanks I
don't usually wear this uh this one but
I said we'll have like a greenish blue
dress on today so I'm doing a whole
it's a whole vibe like a
Greek you know
and it doesn't have anything to do with
werewolves but you know you're right so
here's the thing we did a bunch of
universal monster movies like a few
months ago right we did Dracula we did
Spanish Dracula we did Dracula's
daughter we did Frankenstein we Bride of
Frankenstein we had a creature in the
Black Lagoon
The Mummy we did The Mummy but we
did and then I saw that the wolf man was
on Amazon Prime for free and we were
kind of sleepy last night I'm like hey
it's only an hour and nine minutes yeah
it's short I still fell asleep
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes I didn't know he was in it yeah yeah
yeah I had forgotten he was in it too
yeah he's not um he gets a little
spoiler alert for a movie that's from
1941.
um but he's not he's not in it a real
long time because he gets killed like
pretty early
but um he's great in it I really liked
him in this in this role yeah well I
can't believe he didn't recognize that
voice like as soon as he starts talking
he's in a mustache and everything yeah
well like I said yes played a gypsy well
and he was he was the first werewolf
yeah he became the first werewolf he was
the one that made Lon Chaney into the
werewolf right launch and he got bitten
and killed it with the damn still
and it came yeah killed the wolf
so the original werewolf is dead
and then he became the new one yeah and
he didn't know exactly what was
happening to him but uh I saw him
transform
they did a transformation
it was a 1941 transformation looked like
a dude in a wool suit
weren't around his tits
with an afro it's 1941. it's some fangs
they say I mean Jack Pierce did the
makeup for this just like he did uh for
Frankenstein and everything like that
for the time it was good yeah it's good
for the time and I and I feel like it's
like iconic yeah
um but well they didn't do the thing
about it okay so the wolf man like I
said this wasn't actually Universal's
first werewolf movie uh that would have
been I think Werewolf of London which
came in 1935 which didn't really do all
that well like it didn't make much of a
splash or anything so they had been
talking about doing this one this one I
originally Boris Karloff was supposed to
be in it because they were talking about
it like back in the 30s and then they
just never got around to doing it but it
had a different script back then
so when they eventually got Lon Chaney
to be in it initially the writer of this
movie who's um Kurt syadmack
he wanted the movie to remain ambiguous
as to whether the guy was really turning
into a werewolf or if he just thought he
was turning into a werewolf and so a lot
of the movie because there's not really
a lot of werewolfury in this like Lon
Chaney like when he first transforms
into werewolf it's basically just his
feet you just see his feet and then like
they kind of show him like running
around in the woods and stuff but they
only do the only transformation
transformation they do other than the
feet is at the end after spoiler alert
he gets killed
um and then he turns back into a person
um and they did it with lap dissolves
like they did everything back then so
it's base it's basically like
stop-motion animation like they would do
the makeup and then film a few frames
and then you know put a little more
makeup on and film a few frames and [__]
like that and just like run it in
reverse yeah I fell asleep in the like
last 20 minutes I missed it
um not into any fault of the movie the
movie is kind of relaxing I was [__]
tired yeah and I was trying to fight it
my eyes were [__] and then I'm like
watching it and I hear yeah yeah
[Laughter]
and it was over like when you woke up
because like I said it's pretty short
I'll watch it again it's there were some
things about the movie that stood out as
I've never seen it I had never seen this
movie before I saw it but a very long
time ago maybe I saw it when I was a
little kid and forgot about it
um
a lot of it the Interiors look like it
was shot in location I hit a really nice
[__] old school buildings like [__]
from the 1800s it looked like it looked
they would look like it was real
locations along the place I kind of
wonderful because all the exteriors the
a lot of the exteriors were done in the
Universal Backlot like the European
Village so yeah that they always redress
I'm not sure about the Interiors the
Interiors look like big mansions yeah
um
another thing I noticed about it is that
for 1941
casting isn't real stereotypical for 41.
usually 41 if you're going to have
like a leading man he's actually kind of
a sappy [__] pretty boy really or
they're they were all kind of bland yeah
he had a little bit of grit to him he he
seemed a little bit threatening even
before he was a a vet oh we'll get into
that you're a werewolf yeah before even
before he became a werewolf we'll get
into that a little bit he he seems
[__] lecherously and he seems like
slightly like a bad guy
a bad guy who's kind of passing himself
off as a good guy and he did he had a
rough look to him he was tough
especially for 41.
so that was someone knocking at the
front door
was that a cat trying to get into the
cupboards oh I don't know I hear
somebody knocking is this I'm not
knocking at the front door I'm not gonna
check I mean we have a doorbell right
yeah we have a doorbell so I think there
was a cat trying to open a cover now
they they oh yeah maybe yeah they try to
open up a cat maybe that's what it is
either that or it's somebody outside I'm
not sure yeah oh there's nobody either
but yeah that's pretty weird a mo and
this neighbor working on his [__]
vehicle oh okay yeah because I was like
I couldn't tell where it was coming from
I'm like wow that's really loud no it's
right over there oh he's just out on his
driveway okay well that explains it
never mind I thought somebody's banging
on her door but it's not but um but yeah
well here okay the thing about this Lon
Chaney I mean obviously this is Lon
Chaney Jr uh Lon Chaney senior was you
know Phantom of the Opera and all that
um I you know what I think that I knew
this fact but I had forgotten it until I
was watching a documentary about this
earlier today thank you Jeffy art just
chilling and making salad we're just
chilling and talking about The Wolf Man
and having some vodka or tequila in
Tom's case yeah
um but his name is not Lon Chaney Jr his
name is Creighton Cheney but the studio
said hey once his dad had passed away
sadly
um they're like well now you have to be
Lon Chaney
so they made him change his name yeah
show business right exactly yeah amazing
you know what okay so I had forgotten
too that launching most of them had fake
names too they did yeah most of them did
and yeah and they always kind of had I
always cracked up at how they like
Americanized like a lot of the names
because a lot of the actors were not
Americans a lot of them were
mexican-americans yeah and they and they
changed them to like kind of like white
bread sounding names which I thought was
like super fun oh it's kind of funny
they had they were English names yeah
because uh most you know almost
everybody who had had Irish
[__] rule of Irish immigration
descent she got rid of all the nicknames
mix and Max I got rid of they all just
took English names
that was the odd you had to sound it had
to sound like English back in the day
yeah that's pretty much yeah you got a
German name you changed it to English
yeah but the um the thing about this
that kind of struck me because like I
said I'd seen this before but it was a
really long time ago
and so Lon Chaney plays the grown son of
like a Lord this is supposed to take
place in Wales even though pretty much
everybody has American accents I didn't
even realize it was supposed to be
whales until I looked it up later
but um his dad is Sir John is played by
Claude Rains most famous for invisible
man among other things
Claude Rains was only six years older
than Lon Chaney and I will note that Lon
Chaney is about twice the size of Claude
Rains I mean Lon Chaney was a big dude
like he was very tall and he had like
really broad shoulders and Claude Rains
was kind of more average size like on
smaller side so it's like I'm looking at
him I'm like they look like the same age
for one thing and Lon Chaney looks like
he could bench press clawed brains so I
was like it was very weird like the
dynamic that it was supposed to be like
father and son because it almost seemed
like it should have been the other way
around but it's but honestly it's a
testament to both of their acting that I
kind of forgot about it after a while
like At first I'm like wait that's his
dad they look like the same age but yeah
they were almost the same age because I
did look it up I was curious but yeah so
the original version of this script he
wasn't actually going to turn into a
wolf ever there wasn't going to be like
a transformation type of scene because
um currency admac wanted it to be a
psychological horror film where you
never found out if he was actually
turning into a word like it's possible
he was turning into a werewolf but it's
also possible that he was just thinking
that he was turning into a werewolf and
going out and killing people and like
dissociating so there's a lot I had
forgotten how much of that psychological
stuff there was in this like you know
he's turning into a werewolf because
they show it but it's just kind of like
there's a lot of him
not knowing if he's actually turning
into a wolf and no one believing it
obviously because it's a werewolf so
there were some ambiguity and Cat people
too yeah and that and those two movies
get compared a lot because they're very
similar and we I think we did cat people
as well yeah we reviewed Captain you
haven't seen the old original cat people
you just seeing I love cat people it's
just lesbian as hell that's Jacques yeah
it's good flick yeah I really like that
one a lot
but um or and Val Luton I think was like
the producer on that yeah so if you like
yeah if you like kind of wear creature
kind of not really a monster movie
though kind not no not really we're
we're in psycho thriller yeah with hot
lesbians in it yeah basically and yeah
it got away with a lot Gotta Wait a lot
but you could tell that's what it was
for the name the modern eye I'm not sure
if they did back in the 30s know what
they were talking about well cat people
with 40s 40s yeah so yeah it's right
forward but it was lesbians yeah that
was just one element of it
honestly I kind of feel like cat people
and the wolf man they both have very
strong elements of Noir
you know what I mean so it's almost like
they're I mean the wolf man I think is
more like a monster movie because he
does actually like turn into a werewolf
and like run around and kill people and
[__]
um whereas cat people like I said there
was a lot more ambiguity there yeah but
so it was less a monster maybe but I do
think both of them it's probably cat
people more than this one I kind of feel
like cat people is like super what's
cool about cat people is that they
invented a monster and a lore out of
nothing for as far as I was concerned I
don't think I believe that they made
that monster up well yeah wear cats wear
leopards yeah she just turned into like
a leopard every time she got sexually
aroused yeah did you kill somebody to
turn back
a wild [__] but yeah I think the thing
that a lot of people relate to about
this movie is that Lon Chaney's
character well you said I had forgotten
how um
how uh stalkery I don't know if I want
to go too far in that direction but he's
kind of stalkering he's like kind of uh
sexually aggressive let's put it that
way
even from the beginning like before he
gets bit by a werewolf because I want to
kind of get into that too but um so I
had forgotten about that but a lot of
people like find him a very sympathetic
monster because he doesn't do anything
to deserve what happens to him like it's
just circumstance we got a bit yeah he
just got bit by and he get and I will
add he got bit by a werewolf in the
course of protecting someone else trying
to protect someone because she gets
killed but I'm trying to protect someone
else from getting killed by a werewolf
and he jumps in
and then he gets bit by the werewolf and
then starts turning into a werewolf and
like No One Believes him and it's
interesting because I was thinking this
while I was watching it I was like his
character gets gaslighted the [__] out
of which they don't usually do to male
characters yeah and I thought that was
like really interesting that was kind of
going back to the whole psychological
angle that Kurt Siad Mack was into where
because he was talking more he he wanted
to get play more with the idea of like
like medical or psychological
lycanthropy people that you know they
don't obviously like turn into wolves
but they think that they do yeah my take
on that angle of it is that
the story was telling you that he was a
Chad you know he was a chad
um he wasn't a [__]
um you know
simpy guy or anything
it became a werewolf but it really
wasn't his fault just because he was a
Chad didn't necessarily mean that he
deserved to hit you this yeah he didn't
but yeah I think I think that was the I
think that's where they were trying to
get the sympathy from because maybe they
figured a lot of guys in the audience
would recognize with that recognizing
right yeah yeah he's trying to get laid
too you know what I mean just like you
yeah just like me now he gets bit by a
werewolf and [__] man they'd [__] him
over then the World Turns against him
and and normally probably because I
don't know if this is pre-kaze code or
what no I think this was after that was
okay his Haze code
evil doers had to be punished in the
stories yeah they couldn't get away with
[__] so it could be that that was one of
the they were fulfilling it like this
the main character is the monster he was
the evil doer and he kind of became a
werewolf and that was his punishment
but the evil doing was just she's a
womanizer
trying to get in women's pants well just
this one just one yeah but you know they
lead you to believe that he was kind of
like a cereal you know he was he was a
regular dude right there trying to
change he's a player yeah he's a player
you know and then he ended up on double
dates with a woman you know she wasn't
even a double date it was a yeah I want
to get into that and then she brings her
friend for security
okay all right two two tell you the
price of one all right although he was
bummed out though because he was yeah
well let's see okay I think a lot of
guys would have mentally flipped that
though in the audience of though oh all
right okay yeah too all right I can do
that that's good so I think I think you
know because I was trying to put myself
in the in in the shoes of a dude in the
40s a young guy he's going to interpret
this so I think that was a way of
fulfilling the haze code requirements
but they did it but they were subtly
saying that the dude didn't deserve it
yeah because he still does come across
as a sympathetic character even though I
had forgotten how much a selling point
to the [__] people right he was an
evil doer he's punished because I had
forgotten how much of like kind of a
creep he was at the beginning yeah he's
scary
well he was he he was he
I was kind I was shocked actually I kind
of forgot about and well I was willing
to give the movie some slack because I
was like yeah it's a 1940s and that was
in a lot of movies back then like the
guys were like really persistent yeah
and they're pushy and [__] like that
whereas nowadays people would be like
bro you know what I mean like if that's
stalker Behavior but like back then it
wasn't as back then it was problematic I
guess yeah because uh it's just like you
know if you grew up in a Latin culture
you know with Catholicism the women are
supposed to say no to you they don't
really mean no they just say no so they
can fulfill their honor requirements if
they mean no they slap you that's real
no it's there's different kinds of no
so I that I think it was more standard
back then a woman was supposed to be
demure and a guy was supposed to
right chase after him yeah and I think
that was definitely and they were
available because you see that in a lot
of movies but here's the thing I think
they're leaving out
and the modern audience doesn't pick up
is that even in Latin cultures the dudes
that pursue the women they pursue
because the women gave a signal
there's a subtle signal that she gives
that she's interested so then the
pursuit starts but he knows he's going
to go through this ritual of oh no no no
no no but then they make out don't stop
us enough you know that kind of [__]
yeah it's just probably out of style now
but it was like that back in the 80s in
Brazil easily well I think it was kind
of like that here probably I don't know
probably up until the 60s if a woman
didn't resist you
and call you at the same time then she
was a hoe yeah you know what I mean she
had to say no and yes simultaneously
because what he's a good girl because
what actually because like I said I
hadn't seen this in election probably
since I was a kid or a teenager and so
what happens in this is that so Lon
Chaney's character
Larry Talbot he's been away in America
for 18 years like I said this is taking
place in Wales even though everybody
most people sound like Americans except
for Claude Rains so he comes back to his
ancestral Mansion thing because like I
said his dad is a lord or a sir or
something whatever and so he comes back
to kind of take over the family business
whatever it is
um because his older brother has died in
a hunting accident they never really
elaborate on that or anything but so he
comes back he's been away a long time
you can tell there's some tension
between him and the dad
um because I was reading one review that
said you know these landed gentry and
everything they always do that thing and
there's a there's a word for it it's
called an heir and a spare
um so the older brother was obviously
the heir but he's dead now so now the
spare has to take over so there's a
little bit of resentment because the
younger son like knew that he was just
like oh I'm just like the leftover you
know what I mean so he comes back
so he's working on his dad's because his
dad's got an observatory because you
know as as one does and he's working on
his dad's telescope
and when he's looking through the
telescope like to test the lens or
whatever the [__] he did
he sees uh you know a young woman in the
window like of the antique shop like but
upstairs like across and he's just like
all right you know she's not naked or
anything like that she was just like
getting dressed and be like oh I look
pretty and stuff so okay fine like I
said he's not watching her undress you
know to be fair her curtains were open
but whatever
so he decides like immediately I'm gonna
go over this antique shop and see what I
can see so he goes right over there
water meter yeah yeah and to go over
there and meet her because he was like
you know what I mean so he goes in there
and I thought see okay I thought this
was a little creepy she's hot she's she
is super hot yeah yeah she's gorgeous
she's gorgeous
um what is her name uh
uh Evelyn anchors that's her name
um so yeah she's beautiful yeah 40s
movie stars man they had it going I mean
the glamor yeah fantastic I love that
yeah the makeup yeah just gorgeous
everything is like immaculate yeah so he
goes over there and this is how and he
gets a little he's like a little close
you know what I mean he's like kind of
fogging up on her a little bit so he's
like yeah I'm looking for a pair of
earrings for somebody like a gift for
somebody
that's that's the ruse that he's using
and she pulls out a bunch oh we have
this and that and the other he's like I
don't really like any of those do you
have any that are like like half moon
with like Spangles on him and she's like
no we don't have anything like that and
then he says oh but you do upstairs in
your bedroom and I'm like whoa what like
if some dude came in a shop and like
said that to me I'd be like get the [__]
out or I'm calling the police but she
didn't do that and he doesn't tell her
until much later that he saw her through
the telescope which again is still
creepy he tells her that he's psychic
that's what he says and that he knew
about the earrings and everything like
that but I think if somebody I mean
wouldn't you be weird I mean I know
you're not a chick but it's like
wouldn't you be weirded out if some dude
came in a store and said you know I know
you have a pair like that because I just
saw them on your Dressing Table in your
bedroom I almost say typical male
behavior I'm like that
I'm sorry that is a threat that is a
threat a dude I know all about you baby
had a dream that's what I mean that is a
[__] threat it's just because
sometimes and it's not even so and she's
clearly very uncomfortable
by this information she was trying to
make her [__] he was trying to see
you know spooky I he did seem like he
was trying to and like I said I don't
know because it's like I wasn't alive in
the 40s so I don't really know what the
vibe was man but it's just kind of like
to me again all them swamis and all that
you know what I mean he's right like he
was a man of [__] you know
psychic ability yeah get in her pants I
don't think it's you know I don't think
he was that serious about it I guess but
it's like so he's like okay well I'm not
gonna buy any [__] earrings he's like
so oh well but just buy one of these
canes and this like one has a wolf head
on and everything like that and so he
buys this cane
which is used later on for various
things and when he buys it like there's
this whole thing where he's like oh well
I'll use it tonight when you come and
take a walk with me and she very clearly
this is all she goes no yeah she just
goes no very clearly
oh well I'll pick you up at eight no
yeah
and then he just and then he shows up
anyway you
and then he shows up anyway and she
comes out and she's like oh I'm bringing
my friend Jenny with us not me obviously
because I wasn't alive in 1940. she
expected it I guess so but it's well
yeah because like I said he was very
very persistent they were doing the they
were doing the monkey dance I will note
though that so they take this the third
wheel with him because she's like I'm
bringing my friend along like for
security for [__] blocking purposes and
um for security I would have brought a
big dude along so um it's like hey can I
bring my boyfriend yeah it would have
been like that but um out on this walk
since I already said yeah
she was hot she belonged to you I mean
that's what I said oh I got it I had
just forgotten how blatant it was I got
you in a lot of these movies okay but
that's not the kicker though the kicker
is so they go out on a date
they go to let's go get our fortunes
read in the middle of the foggy woods
because that's apparently where the
where the gypsies have set up
so they go in there Jenny goes in first
to get her Fortune red and they [__]
leave her there they're just like oh
well let's go be alone like over here in
the woods and I'm just like and they
[__] leave her there and indirectly
cause her to get killed because she gets
attacked by the werewolf so that happens
then the kicker is like all of the
people in the um in the village they
find out about this and they're like hey
you got her killed which kind of they
did because they just left her
um I'm not saying she would have died
anyway I'm just saying they were kind of
indirectly responsible but then you find
out later on that that [__] that that
woman is engaged and she's going out
with some random ass dude she just met
yeah yeah and so everybody and there was
kind of they don't say this out right
since 1941 but when Jenny's mom comes to
the Antique shop and like because I
could guess um her like Dad owned the
antique shop or whatever like whatever
that character's name was what was her
name [__] now I can't remember Gwen Gwen
that's right so um so Gwen's dad owns
the antique shop and all the ladies like
Jenny's mom and all the old bitties like
in the village they come and be like one
they got you know they got her killed
they left her out there which like I
said they kind of did and then it's like
and she's engaged and she's out like by
herself with this random man and they
don't call her a hoe but they in in 1941
speak they were like oh that innocent
face is just covering up a little and
then they like interrupt you know what I
mean so you could tell that they were
being like that little Harlot like
running around with some dude that's not
her fiance yeah so well he kind of
insisted yeah I mean you know push
another button he was a very pushy
[__] yeah it all worked out
though well it didn't really because
well I mean it worked out in the sense
that well when her real boyfriend showed
up he was then he started to chill out
he was just remember they were like
kind of trying to be Bros for a second
well I felt like that whole scene where
they were like that Carnival or whatever
that was
and then um he was like I'm gonna show
him I'm not he was just he was well
eating Suitor yeah he said that
um he's like oh well I just want to show
you that I'm not jealous so we'll go and
talk to this Larry Talbot person but
then the first thing that that other
dude does is like oh we have to like do
like this little shooting Booth or
whatever like a competition yeah yeah so
she could like so he's like huh I'm
better than this [__] so there
was that there was like a little yeah
there was like a little dick comparing
they were chill dick measuring contest
it's I think by today's standards it
seems kind of [__]
kind of primitive and blocky and real
pushy yeah but I think what I think it
was like kind of time compressed and
they're just trying to tell the audience
that yeah she had competing suitors yeah
what it was even though like I said I
guess technically she was already
engaged but they kind of mitigated it it
would probably make a move on an Engaged
woman that's not marriage yeah that's
just because they're engaged doesn't
mean they're actually dating they're
virgins
[Laughter]
no they're both virgins yeah
probably and [__] the Lon Chaney
character you could tell he's not a
virgin he's too old to be a virgin
around the [__] block and he's and
he's he's gaming on the women you know
he's trying to get the hottest thing he
can get she's like what 20 years younger
than him
probably I mean maybe not it's hard to
tell like I said he looks like he did in
his 40s I know like people looked older
back then I'm actually not sure maybe it
might only been 35. I'm not sure how old
Lon Chaney was yeah she might remember
when he made the Wolfman he may have
been 35 and she was probably about 20.
yeah maybe or maybe slightly older I'm
not really sure though she's probably
she looked like she's still in her 20s
they got married around 20. very young
18 years she might have even been a late
dinner late might have been the
character may have been supposed to be
in her late teens there's just no you
know you can't look at this through the
modern perspective but after he but they
kind of mitigate it like I said like
when like after he gets bit and likes
well and starts woofing out but like
nobody believes it but she seems to have
like fallen in love with him because at
the end when he comes back and he's like
flipping out being like I'm pretty sure
I murdered some people but I don't like
remember doing it and I'm turning into a
werewolf and [__] like that she was
gonna like run off with him yeah and he
was just like yeah no don't do that
because I'll kill you too please right
he's the main character of course she
likes him more yeah and the the the the
the the her her original Suitor was a
beta compared to [__] launching they
always do that and he's a werewolf so
he's even hotter
that's how that the audience back then
would have interpreted that sure yeah or
and it was a mostly male audience
probably young male audience members you
know looking at this [__] thinking oh
yeah I wish I was a werewolf you know
that's probably what I kind of wish I
was just like there was a lot of that
would be awesome young male dudes
[__] watching Dracula they didn't
want to be [__] Mina's boyfriend they
wanted to be [__] countless okay so
did I yeah it's not just a boy thing
yeah I wanted to be they're living
vicariously through these [__]
monsters
that's true
but yeah so the thing about this now I
will note and I and I know probably why
this was there is a little bit of
um
discontinuity I guess in the plot
because what ends up happening
is that you know when they go on this
the [__] block date with the with the
Third Wheel girl and she gets killed she
gets killed by what appears to be a
regular wolf right and then so Lon
Chaney jumps in
and beats the wolf to death which is
pretty hardcore with it with the K that
he bought
but then later obviously this wolf is a
werewolf and it was Bella Lugosi
so it turns back into a person and so
everybody's like oh you killed a person
you know what I mean like you beat this
person to death but nobody blames him
really they're all just kind of like oh
you know you you saved him like they
think what probably happened was like oh
she did get attacked by a wolf because
they could tell that because it was wolf
Footprints and everything but it's just
like oh and then y'all both jumped in to
save her and there was confusion and you
accidentally beat a dude to death
because that can happen but um but yeah
nobody really thought he was like a
murderer murder but he just kept like
thinking about it and then like the old
gypsy lady who was actually like you
know Bella lugosi's mom she's a great
job she's great she's my favorite
character you did a great job she's
[__] epic in this yeah
um yeah Maria
um
I think that's uh how you pronounce It
tone of this movie is not as dark
say uh Dracula and and retro Dracula and
retro Frankenstein but it has its own
tone yeah it's kind of relaxing in a
weird way it is kind of a
I don't want to say slow but it is
kind of slow there's a lot of exposition
and in a modern take on it I mean I know
they did do that one with Benicio del
Toro which I actually liked I think a
lot of people didn't like it but I kind
of liked it I haven't seen it in a while
you're supposed to be enjoying the
acting and the dialogue and the the set
the sets if they are sets I was kind of
convinced that those were real interior
I mean maybe the Interiors I know the
exteriors are and they're and it's in
these mansions with a bunch of [__]
old-fashioned busts and [__] artwork
it's
trying to give you a very Gothic feel to
it yeah you know it does it I think it
achieves that
the Transformations are not convincing
by today's standards but they're
practical effects with using almost no
technology and they're classic they're
just classic okay that's that's the
Wolfman kind of laughable by today's
standards but that was the original Wolf
Man and it's good to know where it came
from I mean this is where howling came
from
and [__] what is it [__] what's
the one with the British guys the dogs
and dog soldiers and you know it came
you know great flick if you haven't seen
it yeah by the way and I want to read I
want to see wolfen again
I was just you know what I was just
thinking about that today because I was
reading an article about oh the best uh
horror movies of the 80s and a lot of
people were like why isn't wolfen on
this list and I was like I've been
wanting to rewatch that I think you can
rent it for 1.99. this one actually the
tone before I didn't see the end I fell
asleep like the last time the ends got
real good yeah I missed the best part of
it you missed all the good [__] you
still want to see it again because I was
enjoying the movie watching it
um and it was it the tonally I would say
American Werewolf in London [__] kind
of captured the tone of this uncertain
in some ways yeah about it where
I kind of I was kind of respecting more
the American Werewolf in London it did
kind of
I could I could I could see that it was
an homage to this movie yeah even though
that one was a lot more comedic oh yeah
but I mean modern like black comedy yeah
it was a lot more modern but it did kind
of capture that feeling of
kind of a nostalgic comfort
to the movie
which this one was kind of comforting
yeah describe it like I said I think
nowadays they wouldn't have to do as
much Exposition because you know Lon
Chaney's character he's like oh I just
came from America I don't know anything
about werewolves so everybody have to
like tell them about werewolves they do
the werewolf [__] poem five times you
get sick of it yeah I think like I think
at least four four people I told him
that same thing yeah and what was funny
is that
Conrad lent from [__] Venom also
knows Kronos from the black metal band
called Venom in one of his songs I think
I think it's called something about
werewolf or something they you he uses
that yeah that [__] poem
and he tells it you know in his [__]
black metal voice you know satanic but
and I didn't realize that it came from
that yeah and it's not it comes from
this movie that's not like an old poem
or an old legend or nothing like that
yeah um uh curtsy odd Mack the guy that
wrote this screenplay
um he just came up with that yeah heavy
metal Satanist [__] heavy metal Satanism
was directly out of [__] classic
Gothic horror yeah great for the movies
yeah
yeah and [__] Paradise Lost it's
directly out of that the poem we're
talking about and I kind of feel like
everybody knows this uh even a man who
is pure in heart and says his prayers by
Night may become a wolf wolf and the
Autumn Moon is bright interestingly this
particular uh movie
they didn't mention anything having to
do with the full moon because it seemed
he could just kind of turn into a wolf
like whenever and the Gypsy Woman she
could recite this other poem thing it
wasn't really a poem it was just kind of
like a thing that she recited and it
would turn him back it was almost like a
spell like turning back into a human
like she could do that because like I
said it was her son was Bella Lugosi and
he was the the werewolf Tale But
interestingly this movie so this movie
was really successful in 1941 so they
made I believe four sequels to this um
all of them started Lon Chaney As The
Wolf Man um even though it was spoiler
alert he gets beat to death by his own
dad at the end of this which is again
pretty hardcore with the Wolfgang
um but he was brought back for four more
sequels but in the sequels they use that
same poem but they change it to
um when the moon is full and bright
instead of when the Autumn Moon is
bright so they can bring in the whole
phase of the moon thing because in this
one it doesn't really nobody says
anything about a full moon or nobody
says anything about phases of the moon
or anything like that it just seems like
he gets bit and then that night he just
like wolfs out you know what I mean and
then he wolfs out the next night and
[__] like that so there's no like full
moon I don't they don't mention anything
about the full moon in this one
um now they do mention the you know the
silver like silver bullet or like I said
because the cane has like a silver
tipped handle you can beat a werewolf to
death with it you know and and several
people do get I had forgotten how
[__] I remembered that he died at the
end
but I didn't remember that his own dad
beat himself
and I was like that's that's pretty
[__] up getting a drink it's pretty
[__] up that ending
oh yeah so oh yeah Jonesborough oh yeah
I was about to um address that yeah
whatever happened with the only fans
page we're gonna do uh yeah only fans
was too difficult to get on so we went
on uh many vids instead which is kind of
like which was much easier so we put
some videos on there and we still do
streamate
um we did it on we did it like pretty
much every day last week and we're gonna
go on uh tomorrow again as well and we
have some videos on there too but
but yeah so we are still doing it it's
just
we we couldn't get on uh only Vans it
was too much of a pain so we gave up
we gave up many events with much easier
much much easier
but yeah so
I don't know like I I think that out of
all
and I'm not being like uncharitable when
I say this I think out of all the
classic Universal monster movies
I think this is probably my least
favorite
um my favorite would probably
be Bride of Frankenstein although I'm a
big fan of the Mummy too I feel like the
mummy is really kind of like an
underrated one I love love Boris Karloff
and that and I love the makeup in it and
everything
this one is like like I said it's almost
more like a psychological horror or more
like a Noir
um with like some monster movie stuff in
there
um and I think that even though Jack
Pierce did the makeup in this just like
he did on the mummy just like he did on
Frankenstein
um the makeup in this one isn't it's
good but it's not as good as those you
know what I'm saying because it's hard
to because like I said there was some
discontinuity because when Bella Lugosi
supposedly turned into a werewolf like
it was an actual wolf they don't really
show it but everybody says oh I just
thought it was a regular wolf it wasn't
a dude but then like when Lon Chaney you
know gets bit by the werewolf and he
turns into a werewolf he obviously just
looks like Lon Chaney but like with
werewolf makeup on
you know what I mean and it's like they
he they had these um like he said he was
walking around tippy toes yeah those
were like boots kinda there were Cuts
did it cut like that and then they were
covered with Yak hair okay and I was
watching a documentary with Rick Baker
who obviously is like more like a modern
um
uh you know makeup artist who did
American werewolf vanilla in London and
all that and uh he said yeah mostly we
still use Yak hair like for werewolf
stuff and everything like that because
it's just like a really good coarse hair
to use but you know like I said back
then it was 1941 they were still using
lap dissolves so
that was pretty much and this one
doesn't have like a super big like
Transformer transformation scene the
first time he wolfs out they just show
his legs pretty much like his feet like
turning like growing more hair and stuff
and then like the last transformation is
just after he gets beat to death by his
own dad I can't get past that
um he gets beaches by his own dad and
then
um because his dad was kind of like
ambivalent he didn't really believe like
he kind of thought that his son was
losing his mind because he's like dude
I'm you know turning into a werewolf and
he's like no you're not you're just you
know you just got mental problems or
whatever so I I think that he didn't
believe it but maybe deep down he kind
of did believe it so then when he saw it
like after he killed him and then like
the Gypsy lady comes and like says the
spell or whatever and he turns back into
a person like that's kind of a trance
but they just kind of like show his face
and it's like dissolves like him looking
like more and more human and then his
dad is just like [__] you know what I
mean the thing about it um like I said
they made four sequels to this
but weirdly unlike most of the other
Universal monsters
the other Wolfman movies the sequels
didn't have weren't just focused on
Wolfman like all the sequels were like
kind of Monster Mash type stuff like the
next one was like Frankenstein had like
Frankenstein it like Frankenstein meets
The Wolfman or whatever it was
um you know and then like the other ones
like I said had [__] Frankenstein and
Dracula and [__] like that in there so
it's like he didn't really have
you know they didn't do son of Wolfman
they didn't do anything like that like
they did with some of the other monsters
they basically just did
you know Wolfman Standalone and then
they just did like Monster Mash type
stuff that had the Wolfman in it but Lon
Chaney was in all of them but because he
got killed that the first one they
always had to like come up with like
creative [__] ideas to like bring it
back you know what I mean
but I think I think after a few movies
though they're just like [__] it he's
just coming back to life we're not
explaining it so I mean people talk
about movies nowadays at least if you're
making a sequel they at least try to
make it internally consistent I think
back then they didn't really care they
were just kind of like well yeah but he
died in the last one they're like we
don't give a [__] we don't have to
explain he's just alive again just deal
with it you know what I mean they didn't
[__] explain it or nothing like that
but
um oh I forgot too that this one has the
whole
has the whole aspect of
the pentagram being the symbol of
werewolfree which yet it's not a real
pentagram that they show either no and
star yeah you know what's weird is that
well I saw another movie like that too
where they said oh it's a pentagram I'm
like not really that's not what a
pentagram looks like it's that's just
like a like a star like that it's not a
pentagram but um but yeah so they had
that and like when he got bit by the
werewolf like it healed up the bite
healed like overnight and then all that
was left was like this little kind of
thing that looked like a quote-unquote
pentagram that generally just looked
like a star and um also there was
another aspect where the werewolf would
look at a person's hand and if there was
a pentagram in the palm of their hand
that was going to be the next victim
so like at the beginning when Bella
Lugosi who was you know the fortune
teller and he looks at Jenny's Palm
and he sees the pentagram there so he
flips out because he's like oh [__]
she's like the next victim and I'm gonna
kill her and so he's like go away go
away get out of here but she doesn't go
fast enough I guess
um
Sebastian said what about the Spanish
Dracula we actually did um yeah we
talked about the Spanish Dracula better
than the Americans I like it a little
bit but other than Bella Lugosi who is
like [__] classic yeah um but I
actually kind of like the Spanish
Dracula a little bit better and the
Spanish ver the span the Spanish actor
that played the Spanish version of
Dracula I liked him too yeah I liked him
too he had his own yeah kind of more
like Max Shrek
and Bella
but um
Bella Nails the character he played that
on his [__]
you know in in I don't think it was
Broadway but he did it in plays for
[__] yeah a long long time and he had
to be able to kind of [__]
made a lot of the Dracula and vampire
tropes that people think of when they
think of a vampire
um just because of his style
but the Spanish Dracula the way it was
shot and everything how they made use
of the of the special effects and how
they made use of the sets was a superior
it was a lot more interesting the shot
compositions were a lot more interesting
yeah a lot less static more about
Dracula's Brides yeah a little scene was
shown about that it was longer there was
like a little more detail a little bit
more vampire lore in it
um but the Spanish
guy who plays dracula he's good man I
like him
um it's just it's not Bella's take on it
it's just somebody else's take I think I
think it's good yeah the only thing that
wasn't the only scene that
kind of let me down as the scene where
Spanish Dracula smacks the [__]
mirror out of the guy's hand oh yeah it
wasn't quite as cool as [__]
Dracula's or as Bella's version of it
yeah
but other than that no it's good it's a
better movie yeah we did we had like a
long discussion about that because I
think we we made a review we might have
done them like on successive days or
successive weeks we did the Bella Lugosi
Dracula and then we did the Spanish
Dracula like we're in close succession
because we were doing all the universal
movie monster movies but like I said we
hadn't done this one and so I was like
glad that it came up on Amazon Prime
because I was like oh yeah I've been
wanting to do this one because we kind
of forgot about it and I you know I
don't think I've ever seen any of the
sequels like I said I've seen this one
when I was a kid but I don't remember I
might have seen Frankenstein meets The
Wolfman but I don't remember that much
about it like I remember Boris Karloff
was in
either the next one or the one after
that like playing Dr Frankenstein he
wasn't playing the monster
I kind of feel like
who played the monster did Bella Lugosi
play the monster in one of those I don't
know I kind of feel like he might have
but yeah that so they kind of did a
whole thing where
you know he gets brought back to life
and
and then him and Frankenstein's monster
like have a big like wrestling match at
the end which is actually kind of Epic
like I saw like if I can I saw a clip of
it but yeah like I said this isn't my
favorite of the universal monster movies
but it's still like a really good one I
mean there's a reason why all of these
are Classics but you have to kind of
approach it as it's not like I said it's
not as dark it's almost more
it's really more of a psychological
horror movie because that's what they
that's what he intended it to be that's
what the writer intended it to be like
it wasn't going to be like a monster
movie monster movie but you know of
course the studio was like no we have to
have him turn into a werewolf you know
what I mean they knew Their audience I
guess
so they do but there's not a lot of
there's not a lot of screen time devoted
to him being the wolf man it's mostly
him so like I said there's a lot of
um Exposition and there's like a lot of
that kind of stuff more than like
monster fisticuffs or whatever but I I
kind of feel like maybe the you know the
sequels went more in like a Monster Mash
type Direction and probably why all they
just did well you know did well enough
to have four [__] sequels to it
in the 1940s which
I feel like by the time the 1940s
came around
a lot of the universal monsters they
were going it was going more in a
comedic Direction yeah
like Abbott and Costello got involved
um you know what I mean so they so
people started like thinking of them as
less scary and more well because you
know World War II happened and people
saw this Horror in real life and so
they're saying that's like that's not
scary like I've seen some really scary
[__] you know what I mean so it's just
kind of like so then it just became
funny
but I feel like that then it kind of
like went downward and then like 50s
came along and then it was kind of all
like sci-fi like big bug movies and
radiation and all that Carpenter came
though John Carpenter came to show them
some real horror with the thing his
version of the thing and then they
rejected but that took a while they
rejected it which bummed him out man
[__] I think that mentally [__] up
just [__] him up and [__] up his
career
but you know it came out the same time
E.T came out and E.T kicked its ass and
uh it got bad reviews pretty much
because it was just too gross oh it's
just too much and the [__] thing is a
masterpiece it is absolutely not too
much yeah it was just the perfect amount
that he was just the perfect amount even
today just the tone and just the idea
you know
I mean easily one of my favorite yeah
horror movies of all time not just of
the 80s Carpenter takes him just from a
[__] very simple vegetable
Frankenstein alien takes it from that
because it went [__] lovecrafty and
maybe made him a shag off basically is
what that is essentially yeah pretty
much
but yeah so do we have anything else we
would like to add no about the wolf man
anything else you would like to
talk about
no can I sent the link to uh our thing
there he asked for it yeah that yeah on
many vids it's yeah I think it's 13
games 13 gig I spelled out 13. and like
I said on your stream mate it's Jen Tom
cam yeah that's I thought we have some
videos on there but they're just me
because he's not but we do stream on
there yeah but we do stream on there
yeah
you know
but we didn't go on there today because
we had other things we got we're setting
up a we have a Twitter set up but we're
gonna put a link Tree on it and we're
gonna start promoting things kind of
sideways and um promote some of the some
of the other other material that we do
yeah we have been doing things behind
yeah we've been too busy to do [__]
lately you guys will find more about it
later
yeah are we gonna are we gonna say about
that on no not yet Friday we'll talk
about later yeah like Friday maybe
Friday yeah or Wednesday or that we make
a video about it
oh do you want to do that we could do
that maybe we should do that now
everybody everybody's like mystified
yeah let me extreme better well you want
to do it after this one
you just like turn it off and start
another one I don't know no now you
don't want to do that all right
um yeah Joseph says after Universal made
Monster movies funny Hammer Studios made
Monster movies scary again I know right
and God bless him God he also made him
sexy that too Hammer put boobs in the
movie it asked and you know how much
time left yeah
that's [__] hot fresh girls man with
the occasional [__] hot German chick
yeah it was all about all the hot
European lesbian vampires with carmilla
and just
Dad [__] twins with titties twins of
evil yeah yeah
who ended up in Playboy later copious
down blast yeah they're just and and it
and those girls weren't just built they
could act they were good I really like
twins anymore we reviewed that a long
time ago and I and I think I joked on
there I said this should be called down
blast the movie Down blast
you wish you were here but it's a good
movie in its own right you know what I
mean everybody likes Hot twins come on
how can you not laugh that the British
understood the power of titties [__]
big time I feel like they're very
titty-centric culture they like boobs
and Tom can yeah I agree Tom loves boobs
yeah
I like booty too
my big booty
you like pretty much everything yeah
they have things that have its own style
yeah he just likes whatever yeah as long
as the expression is correct yeah
different body styles yeah yeah yeah
he's he just likes it all I like it all
but I have Tendencies well yeah
Joseph also said Thanks for your review
of the Void you're welcome uh I watched
it last night it was very good yeah if
you haven't seen I did it I put it up um
a day or two ago
and um this is actually my second watch
of it and if you haven't seen if you're
into like lovecraftian type of stuff and
if you like 80s horror like you know
John Carpenter or anything like that
um and if you haven't seen the void from
2016 you should definitely check that
out because it's very
it's very uh very much like a John
Carpenter movie
and it has like also has like love card
and and all the um practical effects in
it are really really good it's like
super super gory yeah Sebastian uh we
did bone Tomahawk EXO flick yeah we did
you did that oh my God I love review I
love bone Tomahawk yeah it's like most
of the movies I don't know every now and
then y'all recommend the one that we
haven't done but we've done so many it's
just like it's hard to remember if you
want to see a newer movie that'll remind
you of John Carpenter when he was that
his [__] best to go see VFW Great
[__] yeah we reviewed that one too we
reviewed that one yeah I feel like
there's kind of a you know there there's
been a lot of um filmmakers that are
coming out now that were really inspired
by even if they weren't born then they
were really inspired by John Carpenter
and like 80s movies in particular so
there's a lot of really good
throwback type of movies like I've seen
a ton of them that were really good like
that that you could tell were homage or
were set in the 80s or homage in the 80s
like some I'm trying to think of like
some good there was a good one called
beyond the gates I don't think you saw
it but I saw it
um that was really good and it had
Barbara Crampton in it too yeah she's
still cute yeah she's tired of [__]
still held together yeah she looks yeah
I'm on her Instagram yeah she's still
cute and um she's what 60 something
she's got to be yeah I would think
well look at Cassandra Peterson she's 70
I think 70 something yeah three she's
still [__] real good looking kept up
with herself yeah
Joseph said I looked up the void on IMDb
they recommended a movie called The
endless that one is also great um I
haven't I don't think I've reviewed that
one but I've seen it
that is also very lovecraftian it's love
it it has like a lovecraftian thing but
it's also like
um has a cult like a scary cult kind of
thing going on with it too which I guess
the void does as well but um but yeah
that one is also great so I'd also
recommend that one I just haven't
reviewed that one yet but I have seen it
um let me see yes Sebastian said it was
a good review thank you very much well
it was a good view of this one no the
one that I did um that I put up the
other day the next one I should do I
have to do a book review I haven't
finished the book I'm reading yet but
somebody did send me an arc of like a
novella so I might do that one first
we'll see
yeah Joseph said the endless is on 2B
yeah I really like that movie I really
like that movie so I mean if you haven't
seen it like watch it and tell me what
you thought of it because I really like
it I kind of want to re-watch it
actually I had a good time rewatching
the void because I hadn't seen it for a
few years but yeah
all right so
are we ready yeah to wrap it up okay so
come back on Wednesday night for our
main show and this was a recommendation
by one of y'all and I put it in the poll
and it won quite handily so we're going
to be talking about Princess Diana's
death conspiracy theories okay yeah
that's what we're gonna be talking about
on Wednesday night show so that should
be uh again yeah princess day so I've
been watching documentaries about that
like earlier today so that's what we're
gonna do on Wednesday so hopefully you
guys can join us for that and thank you
for coming and hanging out with us this
Monday evening we will see you guys
again on Wednesday